Three, two, one. Hey, I'm Jeff. I'm Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today while we're still on the subject of worth,
but this is a totally different take. Yeah.
And this is comes from our producer Matt Kielty. So next,
a a slightly different story about worth a story that rather than being about
how much we value our own lives, it's about how much we value someone else's.
Right. And it starts with buzzfeed writer, Gregory Johnson. So, okay.
Maybe you should start with, um, what does now become sort of the infamous uh,
wedding wedding drone strike? Is that,
was that sort of where it started for you? Yeah,
so this strike happens in a very rugged part of the Yemen where there are no
paved roads, no electricity, there's no running water. It's,
there's the mornings, September 12th,
2013 and early that morning in a small village, a group of guys,
roughly 50 to 60 people hooting as soon to be married,
man pile into a bunch of cars and they start driving. This is the convoy,
the wedding convoy. Now in the lead car. This convoy was this man,
his name is Abdula Mohammed LTEC.
We spoke to him through an interpreter in Yemen and
Abdula told me it was his neighbor who was the groom to be married that day
and so they were all driving up to the bride's village and said they got there a
little before noon, ate lunch, recited wedding poems.
After lunch they grabbed the bride and just a few of her bridal attendants,
a few females,
and they start driving back to the groom's village for the actual wedding
ceremony. Now,
Abuelas said that ever since they'd left that morning through lunch all day
long, they heard this humming.
It's sort of metallic worrying. This metallic thumping overhead.
No one in the conflict could see it, but they knew what it was. A drone
Samsung hearing all day.
It's nothing new for people in rural parts of Yemen by this point.
They don't think anything of it. It's common to hear those sounds
so you keep driving basically,
if you can imagine it there sort of winding through these Wattis,
these desert mountainous places
and it's mountainous. They're all strung out on this,
rotted out little dirt track. 11 cars, single file.
Finally they reached this little clearing
up near the top of this cliff where they all slowed down and started to bunch
together because apparently [inaudible] one of the cars that got in a flat,
some guys got out, fixed it, got back in their cars,
didn't right at that moment. The sound shifts somehow.
And then the missiles star,
four of them in quick succession.
The shrapnel is just flying everywhere and it blink and sober.
People are trying to figure out what has happened. All the screaming,
there's fires that are burning and Abdula
[inaudible] his car was torn up. He had shrapnel in his face, in his face,
one in a human release area in the right hand,
left fi one on in the back and outage get done under Afghanistan.
And he says that once he saw there was smoke and his first thought was,
where's my son? And how did you have to get done? My African, uh, he was,
he was a local for his son. His son was there. Yeah.
A young man who had been a few cars back from my son,
had the fourth car on combines, and he was married with two boys and run.
Doctor [inaudible] said he could move.
So he got out of his car and stumbled back toward the fourth car.
[inaudible] I can to find his son. Yeah.
He said they found him just next door
to the car
before. Yes. He,
he died.
It's [inaudible]. No, not for long time. No, he didn't talk to him.
Just he looked at him and
just to pass away.
So it turns out that there are 12 dead.
And typically what happens in Yemen is that as soon as someone is killed,
they're buried very, very shortly thereafter.
What happens here is something different.
The people in the convoy take the bodies of the dead and they take them back to
read though this big town near where the drone strike occurred.
There's a video I have. That's what you're hearing,
where you see some men take these 12 dead bodies and they line them up in the
street on this bright blue tarp and they sort of wrap them in these cheap
blankets.
And so there's this huge crowd that just gathers around to stare at these dead
bodies who are laid out in the street and at a certain point,
this very tiny village, very leathery,
all the emoney who sort of holding onto the back of the pickup with one arm,
he stands over the dead sort of swaying over the bodies and just lecturing the
crowd on what happened. He's just screaming at them. And so
you can hear his voice start to go hoarse
and he's screaming in American drone killed these. It was a massacre.
These people are on their way to wedding. Why did this happen?
Why were they killed?
[inaudible]
why did they target this, this convoy? Well, according to the u s government,
they had received Intel that on that day in this convoy was an al Qaeda
operative named Shockey all bad Dani,
who apparently had been planning attacks against the u s that's why they took
the shot. And in fact they say that he was wounded in this,
in this wedding convoys strike.
And do we have any reason to believe that?
I have no reason to believe it. Greg spent weeks in Yemen,
talked to survivors of the drone, stray, talked to people who were there.
No one knows this guy and Greg says the guy isn't really a member of either of
the tribes that were involved in the wedding.
And so to him it makes no sense that he would be there.
To him this was a terrible mistake
[inaudible]
but what really got me interested in Greg's reporting,
which you can read on buzzfeed.com highly recommend it,
is that he goes really deep into the question of like what the u s did next.
Cause the question is like, what do you do in this case?
How do you repair something like this when you have two totally different
cultures with two different traditions?
How do you find a way to try to make this right?
Mm.
[inaudible] key cans and can, you know, I mean, historically,
do soldiers have an obligation to repair damage? They do. No,
there's no obligation. But a,
what's happened is we've actually created an obligation for ourselves and
Americans have, yeah. Yeah. This has a really long history. A history that's um,
immediately legal. Legally. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Illegal history really.
And there's a, there's a great, uh, law professor at Yale. What's his name? Uh,
his last name is w his wit. It's John Witt. Um, that's me. Uh,
we ended up tracking down John Witt a jet. How are you?
Let's talk about how the u s first started to try to write the wrongs in war.
So what is the foundation story of all this?
That starts with general Pershing in World War One?
[inaudible]
so 1917. All right. Guys called to wow. It's a great war. Ramps up.
So we start shipping young men, millions more to pop over to Europe.
Well [inaudible]
with the France and in charge of these men was a man named John j,
the commander of American forces on the western front, stern man,
handsome mustache, bit of a maverick general person whose, you know,
nickname was, was black jack. And uh,
when he first arrived in France with his troops general black Jack Pershing,
he's got this problem, which is that he has g
spilled in America, ship to France and man by our map.
So World War One is the first war in which the u s um,
is shipping a lot of automobiles,
more than a hundred thousand for the soldiers to drive cars, trucks,
jeeps and jeeps are really great. They get his men from one place to another.
Patty, Damion to, I don't know, messy,
but they also run into French farmers, chickens and cows, children,
sometimes just the farmers themselves with these random collisions or with there
no roads. I'm going to bet there was some of everything.
Sometimes it was probably just ordinary car accidents and sometimes no doubt a
little French wine was involved. So this is Pershing's problem.
He's trying to run a war overseas. And it wasn't any good for him
to have grumpy civilians at his rear.
And so Pershing has an idea which he actually borrows from the bridge and that
is he will use cash money to write our wrongs one.
So he goes to Congress and begs for a statute and congress obliges really
quickly there no sign. This is a controversial thing,
but it was a genuinely new thing because for the first time in a history of war,
as far as we could tell you had a state compensating individuals.
Usually it's state to state.
Here you have state to individuals and said the u s government starts
systematically paying money for the loss of a non American life and war.
How much cheese? I don't know.
It's actually surprisingly hard to find documentation.
I'm mentioning specific amounts, but whatever the amounts were,
it seems to afford
[inaudible].
Christian wrote in his biography that the swift and prompt settlement of claims
had a great effect upon the people.
So it seemed to work really well.
And is this amuse the idea here that like this is what we would do with the
drone strike victims. We talked about that we'd pay them money. Well,
it's actually, it's uh,
it's a bit trickier than that because the thing that Pershing got in world war
one,
it came with a catch and that is that there's a combat exclusion in case you
just walked in. That's Gregory Johnson. And what he means is that this law,
basically what it said is that we'll pay your claims if it didn't happen on the
field of battle. And it wasn't a combat situation.
If it was combat and it was on the field of battle, then tough luck.
That's just war.
So if US soldiers were driving to a fight and they ran their car into somebody
and they damage that car, killed that person,
those people would not be able to get compensation.
Whereas if the U s soldiers were driving to a bar and got in an accident,
they would be able to get compensation. But the problem is
once we get into these counterinsurgency wars,
civilians are suddenly in the middle of the Great John Goes,
I've been made that troops. Carol does money goes 567.
The South Vietnamese civilians during the sweep.
This is in a way the story of modern warfare.
Sirens are beginning to sound over back that President Karzai says he's
delivering his final warning to the u s after u s air strike accidentally killed
more than a dozen mothers and children by the time we get to Afghanistan. Right.
The fighting is happening in the cities,
so there's no difference really between the battlefield and where people live.
And so the line between what's combat related and what's not combat related,
it starts to get
blurry. And so in 2003 and Iraq,
what happened was there were actually people lining up, you know,
there were civilian military operations centers.
People started lining up outside of the saying, my family has been harmed.
I want help. How many people do you remember? If I had to guess,
it was maybe around 80 people or so. Um, that's a ton of people.
Yeah, that's John Tracy.
He was a military lawyer in Iraq in two three and before him, Marla Keenan,
I'm managing director of center for civilians in conflict.
So when they came with a complaint,
what sort is it like you ran over my chicken or you knocked out my window? No,
no, no. Much more serious.
I mean, I think of cluster bombs during the shock and awe campaign.
One of the types of bombs that we were using or the air force was using what
they call cluster munitions.
Basically John says air force planes would fly over these targets and drop a
hundreds and hundreds of these tiny little bombs smaller than a coke can.
And a lot of them would land in maybe a parking lot or a field and they wouldn't
explode. So on a number of occasions you'd have mostly it was kids, right?
Because the kids would see it and they didn't know any better.
It would just run over and kick it and then that's when it would explode.
That's when I'm right. Huh?
I had a lot of those close to a dozen and so that was, uh,
that was a difficult one because, well,
it's combat because the air force dropped it because they were, you know,
bombing the city. Right. But at the same time, days, weeks,
even months have gone by and this thing is just sitting in the ground.
Couldn't we say it's not combat?
And this was a real question that John had to ask his boss.
And then his boss asked his boss,
they eventually sent the question up to the army claims service and they said,
no, it, it's combat,
meaning they're not gonna pay basically like we are in an in an armed conflict.
And this was an unfortunate incident,
but an incident that happened during a lawful combat operation and therefore
we're sorry. And that's basically it. So I said no to a lot of people.
And so like in World War One with general Pershing military officers,
they started lobbying their bosses for an expanded systems so they could start
making more payments and eventually the military does expand it. In fact, um,
I talked to one of the militaries, top lawyers, regular General Richard C.
Gross. I go by rich.
I'm the legal counsel to the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
He told me that around 2006 pain out these kinds of condolence payments actually
became sort of a key part of military strategy. Absolutely.
Even had its own acronym Maus,
m a w s its money as a weapon system,
which you know, I'm not sure that title resonates with everybody,
but it's an interesting phrase for sure. Yeah, exactly. But it's,
it's the idea that money can be used to,
to win hearts and minds that help bring the population over.
And it just got me wondering how much money makes a good weapon.
Well, I haven't liked the u s military hasn't given me access to a database or
anything like that, but three or four years and, and, and interviews,
I've seen different numbers.
Marla says that in 2006 the ACLU filed a foyer request and eventually got their
hands on hundreds of claims files. And in those files,
what you see are a bunch of different numbers,
but one that comes up again and again, $2,500 2,500 by and large.
Hmm. Now someone like John could have paid more,
but that meant they'd have to run the claim up the chain of command. Exactly.
So it was almost like there were these ceilings, 2,500 for a life,
1500 for property damage,
and then eventually the property damage amount got raised to 2,500 is as well.
And that,
that didn't make any sense to me that somebody could get so much for a Toyota
Corolla but you weren't, you were just going to get the same amount, uh,
for lost life. Like I can't get over,
I mean 2,500 seems like just such an [inaudible] a nominal amount and the
practicality of that money of like if you were to kill someone who is the
breadwinner of a family, that $2,500 would,
would not be able to support this family in any way. Right.
But we're not actually trying to pay full compensation. Right? Like,
we're not trying to say,
we think if this 20 year old man had lived to be the average age in Afghanistan,
then he, you know, that it would have been $60,843.
Right? Like that's not the thing. It's you ever, you know,
we had people who were killed here in an attack.
The federal government is one step closer to cutting its first checks,
two families of those killed and injured on September 11th and those people have
been compensated.
Yet the levels of compensation to the New York victims is, is pretty good.
Strap up. Hi.
The range of payments for death claim ranged anywhere from $250,000 to just
under $7 million. You noticed that? I do.
Um, I do,
but it is to a large degree comparing apples and oranges. That's general gross.
Again, because you're talking about a,
a legal system where a country is paying their own victims versus condolences in
a,
in an area where there's no legal obligation to make those payments in the first
place. So that's a very different type of monetary payment. Well,
yes and no. I'm essentially, it's a person's life and yeah,
I mean I think there's an argument to be made that there's an empathy in the
number that you come up with and the amount that you pay for someone's life.
I totally get what you're saying.
The $2,500 I think it's any amount of money.
If I told you 10 would you feel better about it?
I mean you get a little bit better. I think so. Ken,
what does it get you though in the end?
$10,000 doesn't buy anything more back than what you lost.
I don't know what 10 doesn't get to you exactly in Afghanistan,
but my assumption is that it gets you a lot more than 2,500 and but does that
really help you? Is that really what you want? Is the money unimportant to you?
Really? It sounds like the money's really, I'm not a victim,
so I don't know that I can answer that to me if it happened at this point.
Marla told us this story about how before she got into this line of work,
I had several friends who are journalists.
One of those friends was a man named Chris Hondros. Yeah.
He's a photo journalist. He was a photo journalist. And back in 2011,
Chris was on assignment and Libya moving with a rebel group when they were fired
upon. And Chris was. Yeah. Um, and Marla says,
when she found out that it happened,
I wanted someone to explain to me why that happened.
I mean, sorry,
I just want to turn to explain. I think even like,
I knew his family wasn't going to get any money.
I knew that these guys that shot a rocket propelled grenade at him.
We're going to care. No one was going to explain, but I wanted that.
And the money then becomes an occasion for you say like, not just,
I'm sorry, but here's what happened. It's the, here's what happened part.
I think it's the token that's given with the apology and with the explanation,
but it's the apology and the explanation that mattered to you. Yeah.
That's why we call it a men's making amends.
[inaudible]
one of the things that, um, is true of money damages generally is there.
There are desperate effort to find some common language between the,
the party paying and the, and the victim.
Some Esperanto for communicating the meaning of what's happened in a language
that the other side knows matters. That's how John Whip puts it because we,
we see it everywhere we look, we see a part, not just apologies,
sometimes not apologies at all, but we see the, the Almighty dollar,
which is both distressing and also we know it's meaningful.
But the problem is in order for that Esperanto to work,
it has to stay the same meaning to both sides. Which for John Tracy lawyer,
the claim wasn't really about the money at all or not just about the money.
It was as much about the envelope that the money was in or that there was a real
person
there to hand it to them. I wasn't the one who rated their house.
I wasn't the one who killed their daughter, but most of them,
they, you know, just wanted to look at somebody who's in a uniform and say,
you really messed with my life.
Yeah.
And that opportunity is exactly what Abdula LTC
[inaudible] we'll never get to that. I love that too.
That his son was killed by a drone. He never saw operated by a man.
He'll never meet on behalf of the country.
That still doesn't admit it was a mistake.
And so the money he got Kinda the Anti Bill [inaudible] Ah, come on. Ha.
My America feud,
which in the end he says was the equivalent of 30,000 US dollars.
Way more than anyone got in Iraq or Afghanistan. Still.
All he can do without anything else to go on is just compare it mountains.
[inaudible] or he can accept that only if, if, if,
if he gets, you know, the like the payment equal to those,
you know, [inaudible]
do leg in America. How you can be, say someone. Yeah.
Oh, Ooh.
Lost his son, for example, killed if the payment was, if the payment was equal.
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
producer, Matthew Kielty,
big thanks to Gregory Johnson,
writer at large for Buzzfeed who started us off on this adventure when he
brought us to the initial story. Yeah. Also, thanks to Buzzfeed Editors,
Steve Candle,
and do show you by Massawa for helping Matt organize that interview in Yemen
when the country is going through an awful lot of of tumbled,
and he was able to get interviews that we didn't think he could get. Yeah,
absolutely. Thank you to him coming up.
[inaudible].